I have to tell you about something interesting
that's happened in the last 48 hours.
I received a bunch of emails and tweets from
people saying, you know, David, I wasn't planning
to vote for Biden because he's not a progressive.
I don't believe in choosing the lesser of
two evils.
But after Donald Trump's authoritarian nightmare
of a declaration on Monday night about deploying
the military to states, I realize I have to
vote for Joe Biden this these last 72 or so
hours from Donald Trump.
For many of my viewers have become a breaking
point now.
I don't want you to write to me.
I don't need you to write to me and say, not
me, David.
I'm still never voting for Biden, okay?
I'm not talking about you.
What I'm telling you is that I have seen nothing
since the start of this election that has
triggered so many emails from people saying
I was not on board with Biden for this reason
or for that reason.
But over the last three days, I've realized
I have to vote for Biden in November because
this has gone too far.
Check out some of the tweets that were sent
to me.
Here's one quote.
I despise Biden and the Democrats still do,
but at least he won't try to label millions
of our citizens as terrorists and sic the
military on us.
I will crawl over broken glass to vote for
him in the fall.
Another tweet quote, I've been a Bernie supporter
before people knew he existed.
Yet I am Vote Blue to save America 2020 as
a history professor.
I've seen this before.
When you have a chance to halt fascism, you
do it, then fight for a leftist push.
Question what will we do when Trump refuses
to leave the White House?
Another tweet saying, quote, Same here.
That press conference B.S. was the nail in
the coffin.
So, listen, this is logical.
We are now seeing this nascent authoritarianism
come full circle.
And I want to add something that somebody
tweeted to me that I believe is very important
in the context of this conversation.
I got a tweet which said, quote, They need
to be encouraged and not shamed.
And that is exactly right.
We were never going to shame people out of
sitting aside in November.
It wasn't going to work.
I've been talking about the futility of voter
shaming for several weeks, if not months now.
And I'm not going to shame them now.
I have no interest in doing this.
I told you so stuff with the never Biden folks
who are realizing this is a crisis and we've
got to remove Trump.
What I'm going to say is I'm thrilled.
I'm thrilled.
And I knew you would come around.
You are seeing the reality of the situation
for what it is.
Let's get together and defeat Donald Trump.
I'm glad to have you.
No shame here.
No, I told you so here.
None of this stuff.
I encourage everybody to do the exact same
thing.
I know that you know the YouTube comments.
People will say, David, you're so stupid.
I'm stunned.
Always.
Never.
Biden.
I'm not talking about you.
And we don't need everyone.
We just need some people to realize staying
home is not OK.
Right.
Right now, this week, we need to remove Donald
Trump.
If the last 72 hours haven't made that sickeningly
clear, then I don't know that there's anything
left that would convince you.
And in fact, I think, again, without shame,
with total peace and love and curiosity, I
would go back to the folks that are still
never Biden and say, I want to engage with
you now that Donald Trump has continued this
hatred authoritarian slide.
What else do you need to say?
I've got to do it.
I've got to vote for Biden.
Is it some specific policy position?
Is there anything Trump could do that would
get you to say, OK, now he's clearly bad enough
that I'm going to vote for Biden rather than
staying home or voting third party or whatever?
I want to hear from you and I hope that you
will let me know.